Tad's on twitter he said would you say
it's okay for someone to invest in
single stocks after baby step 6
and while also maxing out 15% in the
mutual funds well I tell folks not to
put more than 10% of their total nest
egg in single stocks because single
stocks are risky they're more risky than
mutual funds by far and I personally
don't own one single share of single
stocks not one and here's why the
average guy buying and selling single
stocks several studies backing this up
so you decide you're going to read the
paper you're going to watch Bloomberg or
whatever you're going to do and you're
now dadgum stock expert with your
golfing buddy and you're going to buy
and sell single stocks and you got a
stock tip and you're reading about this
and you're tracking that and you think
you've got an edge the guy doing that
it's almost always guys by the way some
reason ladies are smarter than to do
that but guys will try that stuff and
the average guy doing that makes about
7% on his money lots of studies
indicating that in other words you suck
at it because if you would put that same
amount of money in an S&P 500 no load
growth stock mutual fund you would have
made what the market makes which is 11
and a half or 12 over time and so you're
not kind of you know you don't beat the
market another study that was kind of
humorous they put all the stocks on the
New York Stock Exchange on the wall you
know each of the they were just printed
them out and put them up on the wall and
the names not the actual shares of stock
and they got a monkey and they
blindfolded the monkey and they gave the
monkey darts and they somehow convinced
the monkey the blindfolded monkey to
throw the darts and stick them in the
wall wherever the dart hit that became
the stock in this hypothetical study
that they would buy and hold for the
next two years and so they built a
portfolio by the blindfolded monkey with
darts then they brought in
master portfolio managers and
individuals who thought they were stock
experts and told them to pick their best
poor possible portfolio of single stocks
now here's the thing they didn't really
use a portfolio they said any single
stock you pick one stock you do you know
these shows where they tell you about
one stock and you okay that company what
about this company bulls are bears right
I'm I'm bullish or I'm bearish on that
particular company I like this company
so the blindfolded monkey picks a single
stock with a single dart that sticks in
the wall then they bring in the best
guys in the business who really do know
what they're doing but they were limited
to only picking one stock the
blindfolded monkey over a two-year
period of time beat 90% of the experts
is that because as experts are not as
smart as a blindfolded monkey no that's
not the point the point is a single
stock is so much risk and you just don't
know and they do is an unfair test to
the experts knowledge because the
experts were limited to one single stock
where the experts allowed to build an
actual portfolio of 25 or 30 or 50
stocks they would have outperformed a
random pick by blended folded monkey of
a portfolio because they do know what
they're doing a lot more than you and
your golf anybody do but when you play a
single stock you're nothing better than
a blindfolded monkey that's the point so
I just don't do it it's that that's the
numbers and that's all the actual
probability lands and the chances of you
making money and all that stuff and so
it's a bad hobby is what it is day
traders you remember when day trading
was a big deal a few years ago now
here's the numbers on day trading 92
percent of the day traders lose money
that's all of them you have a better
shot at the slot machine in a cheap
saloon in Vegas than you do day trading
statistically mathematically I mean it's
just it's just plain straight-up stupid
is what it is so having said all that
did if you want to play it because you
just can't stand it then don't put more
than ten percent of your net worth in a
single single stock and in single stocks
because you're not going to keep up with
the market on average you're not going
to do it and if you do it's a fishing
story it's the one time you went fishing
in the one time you caught a big fish
and the bottom line is is that over the
scope of your life the fishing story
does not indicate that one time that you
are a great fisherman it just means one
time you caught a big fish that's all it
means hey guys thanks for watching if
you enjoyed this video click the
subscribe button to get the latest
content and check out these other great
clips from the show so you have to break
the cycle you have to flip this thing on
its head and make it behave you've got
to get so fired up and wired up that
you're broke friends think you've lost
your mind
Oh